Traduttore: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Elena Montrasio
Ieri vi ho parlato di uguaglianza,
di libertà, un po' di filosofia politica,
avventurandomi anche
sul terreno religioso.
Sono un economista,
o almeno questa è stata
la mia qualifica accademica.
Questa sera vengo a parlarvi
di democrazia:
che c'entra certamente con i temi di ieri,
ma lo faccio in una chiave diversa,
essenzialmente descrittiva.
Può suscitare qualche sospetto,
che spero di fugare.
Io penso, comunque,
che occupandosi di una materia
si imparano degli strumenti,
si acquisiscono delle agilità mentali,
delle capacità di collegare le cose,
mettere a fuoco, individuare
la natura dei problemi,
che consentono, anche a uno
che non parte come specialista,
se lavora sul serio,
almeno di provarci
e dire qualche cosa di interessante.
Il tema di questa sera,
che è anche il titolo del libro,
è "Geografia della democrazia",
cioè praticamente di individuare
quanti, quali e dove sono
i paesi democratici, oggi come oggi,
dove e quanti erano un certo tempo fa
e quali caratteristiche ha avuto
questo passaggio, questo processo.
Il primo punto da chiarire
è cosa intendiamo per democrazia.
Democrazia è un concetto assai complesso,
e l'uso che ne faccio io è molto limitato.
La rassegna che faccio
riguarda tutti i paesi del mondo,
quindi quanto più vasta
è l'area che si copre,
tanto più essenziali,
e in qualche modo anche superficiali,
devono essere i tratti che si colgono.
Prima di tutto,
è democrazia di stati nazionali.
Io salto completamente il problema
della democratizzazione
di entità sovranazionali,
[mi occupo] di stati nazionali,
che hanno dei territori ben definiti,
delle popolazioni, degli organi
di governo sugli stessi.
Inoltre è una democrazia di tipo
essenzialmente formale e procedurale.
Sostanzialmente, una democrazia formale
è una democrazia in cui:
sono rispettate
libertà civili e politiche,
in cui c'è pluralità di partiti;
c'è libertà di stampa,
c'è in qualche modo
la cosiddetta "rule of law",
i rapporti sono regolati da leggi,
gli organi politici,
dotati di potere politico,
sono eletti regolarmente
da elezioni libere, regolari e ripetute.
Esiste un certo bilanciamento di poteri.
Questa nozione di democrazia formale
è, in qualche modo, lo "scheletro",
possiamo paragonarla a uno scheletro.
Lo scheletro di un individuo,
o di un animale,
il quale ci dice molto ma non tutto:
possiamo dire che in assenza di scheletro,
o con uno scheletro deforme,
l'animale o non c'è o è mal fatto;
però, anche con uno scheletro regolare,
molto rimane ancora indeterminato.
Quindi la qualità di stati che soddisfano
i requisiti formali della democrazia,
la qualità del loro sistema politico,
delle politiche che producono,
della vita che si sviluppa
all'interno di essi,
può essere assai varia.
Oggi, in Italia, ci lamentiamo molto
del nostro sistema politico,
e giustamente;
però nessuno mette in dubbio
il carattere democratico.
Qui c'è una celebre frase di Churchill:
"È stato detto, spesso,
che la democrazia
è la peggior forma di governo,
ad eccezione di tutte le altre
che sono state provate".
Sembra un paradosso, ma è vero.
Ogni volta che si affronta un problema,
si vede che spesso
le democrazie lo affrontano male,
è facile immaginare
degli altri sistemi politici
che sulla cosa specifica farebbero meglio.
Però, in realtà, l'alternativa
complessiva è peggiore.
Uno dei pregi, dal punto di vista
soprattutto del mio studio,
di questa nozione formale,
o procedurale, della democrazia,
è che si basa su elementi
che sono oggettivamente osservabili -
cioè quello che ho detto:
elezioni regolari,
pluralità di partiti, etc. -
si può vedere dove ci sono
e dove non ci sono
e si possono fare, anche,
delle gradazioni della misura:
qui sono pienamente sviluppati, e là meno.
Non l'ho fatto io:
ho lavorato su dei materiali,
ci sono diversi istituzioni,
la principale di queste va sotto il nome
di "Freedom House", americana,
che ha studiato il fenomeno
dal 1972 ad oggi
e che pubblica regolarmente delle tabelle
nelle quali sono dati punteggi sintetici
per i diversi indicatori di ogni paese.
Vengono dati sia punteggi analitici,
per categorie, sia sintetici.
Accompagnati poi, anche,
da dei testi brevemente descrittivi.
Freedom House usa tre categorie di paesi
che chiama: liberi,
semi liberi e non liberi.
Io nel mio libro ne ho articolate di più,
le ho trasformate in sei,
però qui quello che ci interessa,
sostanzialmente,
è che ho distinto tra quelle
che Freedom House chiama democrazie
che io chiamo "normali", le migliori
e democrazie di bassa qualità,
che sono sempre democrazie
ma hanno degli score più bassi.
Allora, sulla base di questi
possiamo vedere -
come dicevo, si tratta
di dati osservabili -
Questa è la distribuzione
geografica delle democrazie -
qui non c'è la distinzione
tra quelle che io chiamo normali
e quelle di bassa qualità -
nel 1972.
Vedete che al di fuori
dell'area, sostanzialmente, NATO,
fuori di lì abbiamo il Giappone, l'India
e alcuni paesi sudamericani, pochi.
2012, lo scenario è questo.
Qui in verde scuro ci sono
quelle della figura precedente,
in verde chiaro sono le democrazie nuove,
i paesi che si sono democratizzati
e in arancione quelli che, invece,
hanno cessato di essere democratici,
magari scendendo non necessariamente
attraverso la trasformazione
in brutali dittature,
ma certamente attraverso
uno scadimento della democrazia.
Quello che io ho fatto è uno studio,
un empirismo molto elementare,
alla Bacone: le tavole presenze/assenze,
democrazia sì, democrazia no,
eventualmente, magari, in mezzo
e vedere, individuare
una serie di altri fenomeni
che sono in qualche modo, anche loro,
osservabili e correlabili.
Complementare a queste, come dicevo,
ci sono altri due fenomeni.
Qui abbiamo l'aggiunta prevalente
sulla sottrazione delle democrazie;
qui è difficile contarlo,
ma il numero delle democrazie
è all'incirca raddoppiato.
Questo è un fenomeno particolare.
Queste sono quelle che io chiamo
le "democrazie normali",
diciamo quelle compiute ecc.,
che si distribuiscono
in un modo abbastanza curioso
ma che ha un suo significato:
sostanzialmente confinano tra di loro
o sono separate dal mare,
ed il mare è un confine aperto,
è un canale di possibile comunicazione.
Anzi, è difficile bloccare il mare,
è più facile bloccare
un confine terrestre.
Ed hanno alcune caratteristiche,
tra l'altro, sono politicamente affini:
sono legate anche, in genere,
a vari tipi di trattati economici
o anche militari.
L'area superiore è prevalentemente formata
da paesi che sono nella NATO,
sul versante Pacifico c'è il sistema
dell'ANSUR: Giappone ecc.
E l'elemento strategico-militare
ha anche la sua importanza
perché le democrazie
si confrontano con le non democrazie
in modi che non sono, sempre,
troppo pacifici.
Sempre restando a questo livello
di assoluta generalità,
e direi quasi di superficialità,
si possono individuare
alcune classi di fenomeni
che sono frequentemente,
non sistematicamente,
associati con la democrazia,
che quindi possono fornirci
degli embrioni di spiegazione
del perché la democrazia c'è o non c'è
e delle indicazioni riguardo
al suo possibile affermarsi.
Fondamentalmente,
ne avrei individuati tre.
Nel libro mio se ne prendono
in considerazione un numero maggiore,
ma per dare il senso globale
della cosa, sono:
1) grado di sviluppo economico.
Scusate, faccio un passo indietro.
Complementare alla distribuzione
delle democrazie,
che confinano tra di loro -
e quindi, in qualche modo,
il fatto che un paese
confini con una democrazia
tende ad aumentare la sua probabilità
che sia democratico,
o che si democratizzi, se non lo è -
ci sono, anche, degli
zoccoli duri di resistenza.
Qui vediamo i principali.
Sono le tre aree colorate,
sono quelle in cui
la democrazia non è penetrata
e sono l'area marrone là sopra,
tutti quei paesi ex comunisti
nei quali il comunismo non era stato,
semplicemente, portato
da un'occupazione straniera,
come nell'Europa dell'est,
ma in cui era, in qualche modo, autoctono:
la Cina, la Russia,
alcune repubbliche ex sovietiche,
il Vietnam, la Cambogia, ecc.
Quella curiosa isola bianca,
là dentro, è la Mongolia,
che stranamente passa
i test di una democrazia,
seppure di bassa qualità.
Questo a dimostrare che non esistono
né ostacoli, né fattori
favorevoli assoluti.
L'area verde è l'area
arabo-islamica direi,
islamico con la prevalenza arabo-islamica,
anche se lì vengono compresi
anche Afghanistan e Pakistan.
Verrò poi dopo al problema religioso,
che non esclude del tutto,
non rende incompatibile
Islam e democrazia,
però l'Islam mediorientale e nord africano
si è rivelato abbastanza impermeabile:
lo stesso è sembrato, un paio di anni fa,
con le primavere arabe,
[che] questo potesse venire meno.
In qualche modo è stato un fenomeno
certamente significativo,
però da nessuna parte
è arrivato ancora a compimento,
ma dà da pensare che, certamente,
i fermenti ci sono anche lì.
La terza area è l'area africana,
dove il principale fattore di ostacolo
è l'arretratezza, o addirittura
la non piena esistenza, degli stati.
La democrazia è un fenomeno
di stati nazionali:
una condizione perché
uno stato si democratizzi
è che sia uno stato
effettivamente funzionante,
cioè che il governo abbia
il controllo completo del territorio,
che non sia in mano a bande.
In Africa, insieme a tanti altri,
questo fattore gioca,
oltre al fatto che lì
c'è una zona compatta di autocrazie
ed un paese che sta
in mezzo a delle autocrazie
ha certamente delle difficoltà
a democratizzarsi.
Quanto agli altri fattori,
uno è lo sviluppo economico.
Questa è la prossima tabella.
Qui sono raggruppate,
se guardate i colori,
il verde rappresenta le democrazie,
il verde chiarissimo le semi democrazie,
il rosso le autocrazie;
e i quattro gruppi
sono i livelli di reddito procapite,
a parità di potere d'acquisto:
sopra 10.000; tra 5.000 e 10.000;
tra 1.000 e 5.000 e sotto 1.000.
È evidente che c'è una forte correlazione.
I paesi con un reddito procapite
sopra i 10.000 euro
sono per l'82% democratici
e quelli non democratici, lì dentro,
sono tutti paesi produttori di petrolio.
Il petrolio è in sé un ostacolo,
per motivi che adesso
non posso sviluppare,
per lo sviluppo della democrazia.
Se un paese democratico
scopre il petrolio, come la Norvegia,
niente di male, anzi meglio;
se un paese autocratico scopre il petrolio
è molto più difficile
che l'autocrazia scompaia.
Quindi vediamo come
la percentuale delle democrazie
tenda decisamente a salire,
mentre quella delle autocrazie
sia abbastanza stabile
e quella delle semidemocrazie
abbia un andamento strano:
si alza, scende,
fino a ridursi sensibilmente.
Da questo quadro, uno sarebbe tentato
di essere ottimista.
Siccome il mondo economicamente
si sta sviluppando,
e oggi, tra l'altro,
una larga parte dei paesi poveri
si stanno sviluppando economicamente
a dei ritmi abbastanza rapidi,
più o meno andranno dentro là.
Non è detto che sarà così,
perché molti paesi oggi democratici
lo erano già quando erano ancora poveri.
Gli Stati Uniti si sono democratizzati
quando erano un paese ancora arretrato.
Quindi il progresso economico
ci dà delle indicazioni incoraggianti,
ma non sufficienti.
Un altro fattore significativo
è la religione.
La democrazia si è affermata
dapprima in paesi protestanti,
si riteneva difficile
che si sviluppasse in paesi cattolici,
poi lo ha fatto impetuosamente;
oggi, in qualche modo,
vediamo che il cattolicesimo
è in larga maggioranza democratico,
il cristianesimo ortodosso anche;
zone di buddismo, confucianesimo,
induismo anche, lo stesso islamismo,
queste sono in ordine decrescente
di democraticità,
però anche nel mondo islamico
alcune democrazie si sono affermate.
Un altro fattore significativo
che si accompagna -
io ho fatto vedere
come il confinare, la vicinanza fisica
favorisca la democratizzazione,
anche il grado di integrazione economica
certamente favorisce.
Entrare in rapporto con le democrazie
comporta già un certo grado
di democratizzazione,
perché per scambiare,
trattare liberamente con un paese
bisogna fare propria,
conferire ai propri cittadini,
alle proprie imprese
dei gradi di libertà
che consentano loro di comunicare.
Un aspetto significativo delle democrazie
è quello della cosiddetta
"pace democratica".
Le democrazie non si sono mai fatte
guerre tra di loro.
Questo è un fatto puramente empirico:
prima o poi sarà smentito.
Sono state studiate, raccolte
tutte le coppie di stati
che si sono trovate l'uno con l'altro
o in schieramenti opposti.
Non si è mai verificato il caso
in cui paesi democratici
si trovassero su due versanti diversi.
Ripeto, è una regolarità forte,
non è una legge ferrea.
E prima o poi, se la democrazia vivrà
abbastanza a lungo, come io spero,
qualche eccezione si verificherà;
però, certamente,
le probabilità di conflitto
diminuiscono sensibilmente.
Non è che le democrazie
siano necessariamente pacifiche:
hanno fatto tante, tantissime guerre.
Ma le hanno fatte, in genere,
con non democrazie.
Fine!
(Applausi)